SANDEEP GUPTA:
Thank you, Laurence.
So Laurence gave us a
very nice introduction
to what is machine
learning and a glimpse
of some of the
applications that are
possible with machine learning.
So at Google, we saw
the enormous potential
that machine learning
was beginning
to have all around
us, and that led us
to releasing TensorFlow
as an open source platform
back in 2015, and the
objective of doing
that was to give everyone access
to this open source library,
to develop machine
learning solutions,
and thereby, our aim
was to accelerate
the progress and pace of
the development of machine
learning.
So since that time,
TensorFlow has
become enormously successful.
In about these
three years, it has
grown to become the number
1 repository on GitHub
for machine learning,
and we are very
proud to have been named as
the most loved software library
or framework in the 2018 Stack
Overflow Developer Survey.
So all of this success,
actually, in large part
is due to the very enormous
group of users and developers
that we have out there who are
using TensorFlow and building
lot of these interesting
applications.
We are blown away by
these download numbers.
Used more than
17.5 million times.
The number that we
are very proud of
is the more than
1,600 contributors,
and vast majority of them
being non-Google contributors.
And you see very active
engagement by the TensorFlow
Engineering team with the
community in answering issues
and fielding pull
requests and so on.
So it's a very tiring--
an active ecosystem
that TensorFlow
has generated around it.
If you look at where
our users come from,
they come from all
parts of the globe.
So these are self-identified
locations from our users
on GitHub who have
started TensorFlow,
and you'll see that they
come from every time zone
on the Earth--
down in the south,
right up to Antarctica,
and right up in the
Arctic Circle in Norway.
And I think I see a dot there
in Ireland as well, which
might be Laurence, yeah.
So it's used everywhere for
a wide variety of things.
So let me switch gears
and talk a little bit
about the architecture
of TensorFlow-- what
it is, what it lets you do.
So I'll talk briefly about
the APIs that it has,
and then describe the
platforms and the languages
that it supports, and
then take a quick look
at some of the tooling
that really makes it
as a very useful platform
for doing machine
learning and letting you do a
very versatile set of things.
So to look at the
API for TensorFlow,
fundamentally it's a
computation execution engine.
And by that, what we mean is
that you called your machine
learning algorithm--
or your steps,
as Laurence was showing
in that example--
and then TensorFlow
automates all the mechanics
of the training process
and of running it
on your device of interest,
and lets you build that model
and then use it in
practical applications.
So you do this by using
these higher-level APIs
as an easy way to
get started, and we
have two paths of doing this.
Some of you might be
familiar with Keras
as a library for developing
machine learning models,
and TensorFlow has full
tight integration with Keras,
and in fact, Keras is the
preferred high-level way
of building machine
learning models
using these LEGO bricks, which
let you piece together models
one layer at a time and build
pretty complex architectures.
So you can use
the Keras library.
In addition, we also package
some of these very commonly
used models by what
we call estimators,
and these packaged models are
battle tested and hardened,
and they let you
do your job quickly
based on architectures that have
already proven to be valuable.
And there's also a
lot of flexibility
in customizing things
and changing things
and wiring them anyway you
need to for your application.
So these APIs for model
building are fed by data,
and part of what
TensorFlow offers
is very flexible libraries for
building these data pipelines--
for bringing in data
into your models,
and then doing some of
the feature transformation
or pre-processing to
prepare the data so
that it's ready to be ingested
by a machine learning model.
And then once you
have all this set up,
then we have this
distribution layer,
which basically deals with
abstracting away your model
and distributing your
training job to run
on a CPU or single
GPU or multiple GPUs,
or even on custom
architectures such as TPUs,
which we'll talk a little bit
more about as we go forward.
So having trained
your model, then, you
save your model as an object.
And this object
basically captures
the architecture of
the model, as well as
the rates and the
tuning of the knobs
that you did during
your training phase,
and now it's ready for
use in your application.
And that's where
you, again, have
a very flexible choice of how
to use that trained model.
You can use a library such
as tf.serving to manage
the whole process of serving.
You can deploy it on mobile
devices or using TensorFlow.js.
You can deploy it
in the browser.
And we'll talk more about
all of these later today,
as well as the
dedicated talks on each
of these components, where
you can learn more about them.
So on the platform side,
as I was saying earlier,
TensorFlow lets you run
your machine learning models
on CPUs, GPUs, as well
as on these custom
hardwares such as TPUs, as
well as on the mobile devices,
be it Android or iOS
framework, and then
going forward on lots of these
embedded IoT type devices.
So talking a little bit
more about the platforms,
one platform that we're
particularly excited about
is Cloud TPUs.
So Cloud TPUs were announced
by Google actually last year,
and then this version
2 of the Cloud TPUs
was made general availability
earlier this year.
And these are
specially-designed pieces
of hardware from
the ground-up which
are really, really
optimized for machine
learning type of workloads.
So they're blazingly
fast for that.
Some of the specs are they're
extremely high performance
in terms of compute, as
well as a large amount
of very high bandwidth
memory, which
lets you parallelize
your training job
and take full advantage of
this kind of an architecture.
And the nice thing is that
TensorFlow is the programming
environment for Cloud TPUs,
so TensorFlow is very tightly
coupled with being able to do
this seamlessly and easily.
So let's see what's possible
wirh these types of devices.
Here I'm showing
you some numbers
from training, what's
called the ResNet-50 model.
So ResNet-50 is one of the
most commonly used models
for image classification.
It's a very complex
deep learning
model which has 50 layers.
Has been named ResNet-50.
And it has more than 20
million tunable parameters,
which you have to optimize
during the course of training.
So this turns out to be a
very commonly used benchmark
to look at
performance of machine
learning tools and models to
compare how well the system is
optimized.
So we train the ResNet-50
model on a public data set
called ImageNet, which is a
data set of tens of millions
of images that are labeled
for object recognition
type of tasks.
And this model could be trained
on Cloud TPUs for a total cost
of less than $40 with an
extremely high image throughput
rate, which is mentioned there.
And that lets you take the
entire ImageNet data set
and train your
model, in a matter
of tens of minutes, what used
to take hours, if not days,
a few months or years ago.
So really exciting to see
the pace of this development
to do machine learning at scale.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
we see enormous growth
in the capabilities
of these small
minicomputer devices
that we carry around
in our pockets.
Smartphones, smart connected
devices, IoT devices--
these are exploding.
And I think by some
counts, their estimates
are that there will be about
30 billion such devices
within the next five years.
And there are a lot of
machine learning applications
that are possible on
these types of devices.
So we have made it a priority
to make sure that TensorFlow
runs-- and runs well--
on these types of
devices by releasing
a library called
TensorFlow Lite.
So TensorFlow Lite is
a lightweight version
of TensorFlow, and this
is how the workflow works.
You take a TensorFlow model,
and you train it offline--
let's say on a workstation
or in distributed computing.
And you create your saved model.
That saved model then goes
through a converter process
where we convert it into a
model that's specifically
optimized for mobile devices.
We call it the
TensorFlow Lite format.
So this TensorFlow
Lite model can now
be installed on a mobile
device where we also
have a runtime for TensorFlow,
which is a TensorFlow Lite
interpreter.
So it takes this
model, and it runs it.
It binds to the local hardware
acceleration-- custom hardware
acceleration-- on that device--
for example, on Android.
You have the NNAPI interface--
the Neural Network interface--
which takes advantage of
whatever might be the hardware
configuration, and this gives
you a model that's lightweight.
It uses less memory,
less power consumption,
and is fast for
user mobile devices.
So here's an example of how
this might look in practice.
What you're seeing here is a
image classification example
running on a mobile phone, and
we are holding common office
objects in front of it, and it's
classifying them in real time--
scissors and Post-its, and
obviously, a TensorFlow logo.
So it's very easy to build
these types of models
and get these applications
up-and-running very quickly,
and there are
examples and tutorials
on our YouTube channel to
show you how to do this.
So in addition to the
flexibility on the platform
side, TensorFlow also gives
you a lot of flexibility
in programming languages that
you can use to call it in.
So we've always had a large
collection of languages
that have been supported.
Python continues to be the
mainstay of machine learning,
and lot of work being
done in that area.
But you can see
many more languages,
and most of these, actually,
have been developed
through community support.
Two languages we are
particularly excited about,
which we launched
earlier this year--
one is support for Swift.
So Swift gives some
unique advantages
by combining the benefits of
a very intuitive, imperative
programming style with the
benefits of a compiled language
so you get all the
performance optimizations
that graphs typically
bring you, and so you
can have best of both worlds.
Another language that's
extremely exciting
is bringing machine
learning to JavaScript.
There's a huge JavaScript
and web developer community
out there, and we believe that
by using TensorFlow.js, which
is the JavaScript
version of TensorFlow,
it lets JavaScript
developers easily
jump into machine learning
and develop models
in the browser using
JavaScript, or run it
with a node server backend.
So we're beginning to see
some really cool applications
of this, and I'll show you
two examples of that here.
So this is a tool which you can
try out yourself on that site
up there.
It's called
TensorFlow Playground,
and this lets you
interact with a machine
learning model with a neural
network very interactively
in the browser.
So you can define a simple
neural network model.
You can control how
many layers it has,
how many nodes it
has, and then you
can see the effect of
changing parameters
like learning rates,
et cetera, and look
at how individual
neurons are behaving
and what's happening to
your model convergence.
And these are the types of
interactive visualizations
that are really
possible when you
have a browser as a platform
for machine learning.
On the TensorFlow.js
website, you
can see a lot more
really fun examples.
My favorite one is the one
which lets you drive a "Pac-Man"
game by using hand
gestures or gestures.
This one is an example of the
PoseNet model, where a machine
learning model can
be fed to webcam data
to identify human pose,
and then this data
can be used to drive
or control actions.
So again, all the source code
for this model is available,
and the model is also
available in trained
from that you can use.
So just finally, I want
to talk a little bit
about some of the tooling
that makes TensorFlow
very flexible and easy to use
for a variety of applications.
One example of such a
tool is TensorBoard.
So TensorBoard is the
visualization suite
that comes with TensorFlow,
and by using TensorBoard
you can dive into the
complexities of your model,
and you can look at the
architecture of the model.
You can see how the
graph is laid out.
You can break down your data.
You can see how the data is
flowing through the network,
look at some convergence
metrics and accuracy and so on.
It's a very powerful way of
working with your machine
learning models.
What you're seeing
here is a visualization
of the MNIST data set, which
is the handwritten digit
recognition data set.
And you can see how
your data set clusters,
and whether you have
a good distribution
of different types of
labels in your data,
and how they are separated.
So we talked a lot about machine
learning model development.
It turns out that in
order to put machine
learning into practice and
really using it in a production
setting, it takes a lot more
than just the model itself.
So you have to deal with
a lot of things related
to bringing the data
in, and then dealing
with model serving,
model management,
and evaluating the
performance of models
and keeping them
refreshed over time,
and the lifecycle
management of models.
So for this, we
recently open sourced
an extension to TensorFlow
called TensorFlow Extended,
which really deals with this
process of end-to-end machine
learning and gives
you a lot of tools
that you can use to deal with
these system-level aspects
of end-to-end machine learning.
And my colleague [? Clemens ?]
has a talk later this afternoon
where he dives into more
details about what all
you can do with this platform.
So with this brief
introduction to TensorFlow,
let me turn it back
to Laurence, who
will show how we are making it
easier to use and get started.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, Sandeep.
My mic still working?
There we go.
So Sandeep showed TensorFlow
and some of the things
that we've been able
to do in TensorFlow
and what it's all about.
One of the themes that we've
had for this year in TensorFlow
is to try and make it
easier for developers.
So what I want to share
is four of the things
that we've actually worked on.
The first of these is Keras.
Sandeep mentioned, if
you're familiar with Keras,
it was an open source
community framework
that it made it easy for you to
design and train neural nets.
Francois, the inventor of
Keras, now actually works for us
at Google, and as
a result, we've
incorporated Keras
us into TensorFlow.
And to be able to use
Keras in TensorFlow,
it's as easy as from
tf import keras.
The second thing that
we've been working on
is something called
Eager Execution.
And so I came to TensorFlow as
a coder, not as an AI scientist
or as a data scientist,
and the first thing
that I found that it was very
difficult for me to understand
was how a lot of the things
that you do in TensorFlow
was that you write all
your code up front,
you load it into a graph,
and then you execute it.
And it was hard for me, as
a developer, to understand,
because I don't know about you,
I'm not a very good developer.
I need to write two or
three lines of code,
step through them,
make sure they work.
Write another two or three lines
of code, step through them,
make sure that they work.
And one of the things
that we've added
is what we've called
Eager Execution to make
that possible.
So instead of loading
everything into a graph
and then executing
on a graph, you
can actually do
step-by-step execution now
with Eager in your
TensorFlow application.
So you can debug
your data pipelines.
You can debug your training
and all that kind of stuff.
I love it.
It makes it a lot easier.
The third one is something
that we've released
called TensorFlow Hub.
And the idea behind
TensorFlow Hub
is that it's a repository
of pre-trained models
that you can then just
incorporate directly
in your app with one
or two lines of code.
And not only can you
incorporate the entire model,
but through transfer
of learning,
you can actually just
pull individual layers
or individual attributes of a
model and use them in your code
as well.
The idea behind that is really
to get you up-and-running,
get you started quickly in
common scenarios such as image
classification,
text classification,
that type of thing.
And then the final one is--
really it's been designed
to help researchers
and to make it a lot
easier for researchers,
and it's called Tensor2Tensor.
And the idea, again,
behind Tensor2Tensor
is to give you
pre-trained models
and pre-trained scenarios that
you can use, you can reuse,
and you can start
adapting really quickly.
But let me start looking
at a couple of these.
So first of all is Keras.
Now, the idea is Keras-- it's a
high-level neural network API.
It was built in Python.
It's designed to
make it easy for you,
as I've mentioned, to
build a neural network.
And one of the
things that it does
is it includes the
ability to access
various different namespaces--
sorry, it allows you to
access various different--
sorry, my slides
animation are broken--
access different data sets.
So for example, one data
set that's built into it
is called Fashion-MNIST.
The graph that Sandeep showed
earlier for handwriting
recognition is MNIST.
This similar one,
called Fashion-MNIST,
allows you to do
a classification
on items of clothing.
And in the next
session after this one,
I'm actually going to show
all the code for that--
that you can build a
classifier are using
Keras or TensorFlow to
classify items of clothing
in about 12 lines of code.
So I'm going to show that a
little bit later on if you
want to stick around for that.
But very, very easy for you
to use, as you can see here.
This is in Keras.
If I wanted to use something
like Fashion-MNIST,
I could just incorporate
the data set.
And if I want to build
a neural network--
this neural network is actually
what will classify the clothing
that I mentioned earlier on,
so these three lines of code--
these three layers--
are what you'll use to
define a neural network that
can be fed an item
of clothing and it
will tell you what it is.
So Keras-- designed to
make all of that simple.
Eager Execution--
very similar thing.
The idea is it's an imperative
programming environment.
It evaluates
operations immediately.
You don't build graphs,
and your operations
will return concrete
values so you
can debug them straight away.
And to turn it on in TensorFlow,
all you have to do is say
tf.enable_eager_execution.
And if you use, for example,
an IDE like PyCharm,
that then enables you to
do step-by-step debugging
through the Python that you're
using to build your model
and test your model.
So TensorFlow Hub--
the idea is it's
a library of model
components that we've
designed to make it easy
for you to integrate
these pre-trained models
into your application,
or even pull individual layers
through transfer of learning
into your application, and
it's just a single line of code
to integrate them.
And here's a sample piece
of code here for it,
where the idea is that I'm now--
the first three
lines there is I'm
calling on hub.Module to
bring in this nasnet model,
and then those bottom
three lines of code
is I could just pull
things out of that.
So for example, features
= module (my_images)
is going to give me the set
of features in that model.
So I can inspect them,
I can adapt them,
and I can maybe build my
own models using them.
And other things like the
logics and the probabilities,
I can actually pull out of
that just using method calls.
So if you've ever done some
simple TensorFlow programming,
you might have seen--
for example, on GitHub,
there were models
such as ImageNet
that you could download
and start using.
This brings that
to the next level.
Instead of you
downloading a model,
putting it somewhere,
writing code to read that in,
the idea is that there's an
API for you to pull it out,
and also to inspect the
properties of that model
and use them yourself.
And then finally,
Tensor2Tensor-- the idea
is that this is similar in that
it's a library of deep learning
models and data
sets we've designed
that's really for
deep learning research
to make it more accessible.
So for example, if the latest
adaptive learning rate method,
I think is what
we're showing here,
then the idea is I
can actually pull that
in using Tensor2Tensor,
and in this case,
the code is actually--
this is for translation.
So I can pull in the latest
research on translation.
I believe this one
English to German.
And I can use that
in my own models,
or I could build my own
models wrapping them.
So again, really, the whole
idea is to take existing models
and to make building your own
machine learned applications
using those models
a lot simpler.
So those are four
of the advances
that we've been working
on in this year.
The whole idea, like
we said-- the theme
is to make machine
learning easier.
First is Keras for
building neural networks.
Make it very simple.
The second is Eager
Execution to make life
easier for programmers so
you've got imperative execution.
The third, then, is pre-trained
finished models and providing
a repository for them
so that you can just
pull them out using
a single line of code
and not go through
all that friction.
And then finally, and
more cutting-edge stuff
is Tensor2Tensor, where
some of the latest research
is available, and code that's
been written by our researchers
is available for you to be able
to incorporate their models
and their work into your own.
So with that, the most important
thing for us, of course,
is community and to be
able to extend TensorFlow
through a community,
as Sandeep shared.
And Edd, who's our
specialist in community,
will share that with you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
EDD WILDER-JAMES
Thanks, Laurence.
Hey, everybody.
My name's Edd Wilder-James,
and as Laurence said,
I work on growing open
source collaboration
around TensorFlow.
The most important
thing is that we
want machine learning to be
in as many hands as possible.
So firstly, thank
you for being here.
And there's one reason that
we've convened these two
days in this conference
where you can come and learn
about TensorFlow not from
people five-step-removed
from the project, but from the
actual developers and product
managers who are working
on all the features.
So please stick with
us for this track,
because you'll be getting it
absolutely from the source.
Talking about source--
so TensorFlow does
have a massive
worldwide community,
and we'd love you to
be involved in it.
There's two places you
really need to know about.
The first of these is
tensorflow.org/community.
Anything we talk about
today, where it's just
a resource or a user
group or a mailing list,
you can find from there.
So if you're a
user of TensorFlow
and haven't joined up, maybe,
to the discuss mailing list,
or you don't use Dtack
Overflow to get your answers,
or you don't use GitHub
Issues to file when you've
got a really gnarly problem,
please head over and get
familiar with those resources.
One of the other unique
things about these resources
is who's on the end
of the issue, who's
on the end of the Stack
Overflow question.
It's actually a member
of the TensorFlow team
at Google Brian, a
lot of the time, who's
going to answer your question.
We really believe that we should
be connected directly to users
and be learning from use
cases and helping out,
so we actually have
engineers who basically
do a rotation taking turns to
answer Stack Overflow questions
and address issues.
It's really getting
right to the heart
of the team when you file this.
And one of the unique
characteristics
about TensorFlow as
an open source project
is you are using the exact same
code we use inside Google when
you're using TensorFlow.
There's no two versions.
It's the same code.
So you're reaching
the same folks,
and your issues have
a similar eye on them
as any other person
inside Google's world.
The other thing we
really want to do
is encourage and grow
more contributors.
So if you're a
developer and want
to become involved
contributing to TensorFlow,
there's a developer's
mailing list, again,
you can find up there.
And on that mailing list,
we do a lot of things
like coordinating releases.
We also, now, starting in
the middle of this year,
publish requests for
comments around new designs.
As you'll probably
hear later, we're
in the middle of figuring out
what TensorFlow 2.0 is going
to look like, and a
big part of that for us
is public consultation
on design.
So if you're a heavy
user or developer,
please play a part
in that review.
You can join that, again,
through the community page.
One other great resource--
this is on the other side,
if you're new-- is Colabs.
Has anyone here
used a Colab at all?
OK, a few people.
So this is a really
exciting thing
that we brought
online this year.
Basically, you can use
compute resource free, on us,
in collabs where TensorFlow is
all set up and ready to use.
And one of the easiest
ways of getting into this
is if you're on the
tensorflow.org website
and you see code examples, you
see the Open in Colab button.
And you hit that, boom, you're
in a Jupyter notebook running
TensorFlow, and you get access--
for a limited time, obviously--
to GPUs that we provide.
So it really is an amazing
way that you don't have
to worry about the resource.
You don't have to
worry about installing.
You just don't even have to
worry about writing the code.
You can actually take an example
and then start tweaking it
straight online, and it's
one of the best learning
tools for playing
around with TensorFlow.
And the other fun
attributes of this
are you can save your work
to your Google Drive account
so it's not lost,
and you can also
start up a colab from
any GitHub repository.
So it's a pretty powerful tool.
OK, a few other things that
are good places to hang out.
We have a YouTube channel.
And if you enjoyed
Laurence talking,
you can just literally
have hours of Laurence
talking and talking
about TensorFlow.
But one of the fun things
he does there, as well, is
gets out into the user
base and to the developers
and interviews people who
are using TensorFlow as well.
So if you have a useful
and interesting application
in TensorFlow, come and find us.
We'd love to talk to you.
We'd love to profile you,
because these things aren't
just for us to broadcast out.
We want to celebrate
the community.
Likewise, we have
a blog, which you
can find on Medium or
blog.tensorflow.org.
And as well as
publishing, I think,
what is a really great
resource for technical articles
and important information
about TensorFlow there,
we're, again, incorporating
content from the broader
developer community.
So if you're interested
in guest blogging,
again, come talk to us.
We'd love to have a lot of
content that reflects everybody
using the code.
And of course, there's
this little thing
called Twitter, which is our
main newswire for everything
that tickers over-- so releases,
important articles, and things
like that.
We'd love you to hook
into all those things.
We'd love you to talk us over
the course of these two days.
We also have a presence at the
booth over in the expo area--
the [INAUDIBLE]--
and we're hanging
around, made sure
that we got a good
rotation of people
to come that you could talk to.
So even if we don't know the
right answer to your question,
we'll probably be able to say,
well, so-and-so is over there.
Come and talk to him.
This is your best chance to
get face-to-face information
from us, basically.
So thank you very much
for your attention so far.
I know Laurence is going to
speak shortly and guide us
into the two days.
Very grateful for
you being here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]